er hat es tatsächlich geschafft allen
masc die batterie fahren in australien
in weniger als 100 tagen gebaut wir
hatten ja hier schon mal vermutet dass
die batterie viel früher starten aber
die power pack celebration im september
war wohl nur eine kleine feier jetzt
aber ist es so weit wie weit genau und
warum machst jetzt 50 millionen dollar
spart jetzt sind es zurzeit fiction
herzlich willkommen es ist ein absolut
sensationelles projekt die größte
batterie farben der welt am 10 märz hat
der masken twittert dass tesla die
energieprobleme des bundesstaats
südaustralien in 100 tagen lösen wolle
und darauf würde er wetten sind aus
reihen leidet darunter dass immer mehr
kohlekraftwerke abgeschaltet wurden und
windparks und gaskraftwerke jetzt nicht
in der lage sind ausreichend strom zu
produzieren um die belastungsspitzen
abzufangen immer wieder kommt es dort zu
stromausfällen
ein systembedingt das problem
regenerativer energien egal ob
solarzellen oder windkraftwerke der
strom steht nicht dauerhaft zur
verfügung allen masc lösung für dieses
problem ein netzwerk aus batterien er
will die energieversorgung
revolutionieren dazu gehören solar
dachziegel und die power wort batterien
und batterie farben seine vision ein
netzwerk mit batterien in wohnungen und
häusern und batterie farben und die
stromerzeugung aus der sonne mit tesla
seiner ziegen und für die tesla
elektroautos wird so preiswert und
umweltfreundlich strom erzeugt und
erscheint dazu tatsächlich relativ
problemlos in der lage zu sein
mit der fertigung des tester modells
drei hat er ja riesige problem er kann
die produktion einfach nicht richtig
starten
noch wird das model 3 quasi von hand in
extrem niedrigen stückzahlen gefertigt
schon wird es hat deshalb ein frühes
ende vorausgesagt aber maske hält
dagegen gerade hat er den tesla strom
lkw vorgestellt und einen
supersportwagen der 400 kilometer pro
stunde schnell sein soll und in 1,9
sekunden von 0 auf 100 beschleunigen
soll
maske kann von seinen problemen ablenken
aber in aus reihen hat er jetzt
geliefert und hat gezeigt dass er auch
super ehrgeizige zeitpläne einhalten
kann am ersten september wurde der
vertrag für die batterie farm
unterzeichnet und jetzt ist es soweit
schon nach knapp 90 tagen und das war
auch bitter nötig denn jetzt fängt in
australien die heiße jahreszeit
an der sommer auf der südhalbkugel ist
ja genau dann wenn bei uns winter ist
und da werden die klimaanlagen
eingeschaltet und ordentlich
stromverbrauch für die batterien fahren
in australien ist deshalb eine riesen
wette eingegangen erwartete die farm in
100 tagen zu bauen
dabei wird sie eine kapazität von 100
megawatt haben sie ist in der lage
30.000 häuser mit strom zu versorgen
was ist sie damit dreimal stärker als
jede bisher auf der welt gebaute
batterie farm in kalifornien hatte tesla
bereits eine fast batterien anfang 2017
fertiggestellt damals brauchte tesla 90
tage für 20 megawatt für den klimawandel
sind das auf jeden fall gute nachrichten
und auch für deutschland sind solche
batterien fahren ja extrem interessant
wenn wir komplett aus der
kohleverstromung aussteigen wollen dann
sind sie nötig zu all diesen themen
halte ich euch natürlich hier auf dem
laufenden wenn ihr kein video verpassen
wollten dann sollten aber aufs auge und
vor allem gibt mir einen auf die glocke
hier geht es weiter mit dafür
draufklicken mit tempo 200 unterirdisch
durch die stadt darin routiniert maske
mal eben den innerstädtischen verkehr
das ist wirklich ziemlich irre also bis
dann bleibt dran